the crazy thing about email is that it
was really invented as a productivity
tool obviously and it's good for a lot
of things it's kind of Shrunk the world
a little bit you can communicate with
people halfway around the world but it's
actually a really bad communication tool
and the basic problem is that you can't
read tone or body language in emails so
things get lost in translation and to me
that's really the key phrase you send
somebody an email that strikes you is
incredibly simple and clear something
like saying the sky is blue the ocean is
deep but then you get this email back
from the person that suggests they
completely misinterpreted what you said
and then you might get your back up and
sort of crack your knuckles and start
typing a response that you're gonna fire
back at them and this kind of stuff
happens all the time and it can chew up
a lot of time as well and again this is
part of the irony email is supposed to
be this productivity tool but you can
get into these disagreements over email
that can chew up an entire afternoon
whereas if you just walk down the hall
talk to somebody in person you could
probably solve whatever problem there is
in two minutes and actually build a
relationship because if you think of
culture is just kind of the sum total of
the relationships that that colleagues
have with each other the thing about
email is that it does literally nothing
to build those relationships and is more
likely to actually damage whatever
connective tissue is there in the first
place and we've seen this behavior all
the time in all our own jobs where
people start these CC loops going and
then suddenly you've got people like
picking sides on an issue one CEO had a
great line she said that email taps in a
really bad part of our brain which is
the part that always wants to have the
last word in a discussion and I'm sure a
lot of people have seen that so I've
talked to a lot of leaders who have
established very clear rules about email
and their organizations such as you're
not allowed to argue over email you
might have one back-and-forth in which
two people are disagreeing about
something
but after that he said you've got to get
on skype pick up the phone or walk down
the hall because again things can spiral
out of control Jeff Weiner of LinkedIn
at a good line he said you know if you
want to get fewer emails because that's
what a lot of people say it's like how
can I not work an email I get so many of
them but he says if you want to get
fewer emails there's a very simple way
to do it send fewer emails you know the
fewer you send that's going to avoid
those sort of you know five back and
forth that can chew up a day so quickly
so again a phone call Skype just walking
down the hall can be so much more
effective and will actually build those
relationships that are so important to
culture